bonjour monsieur bigras est ce que je
peux aller vos points de vue cavanna
j'ai besoin d'un break j'ai vraiment
trop d'argent
on va vous voir tout l'été dans le film
la chute de l'empiré américain de denys
arcand tenir quant à mon avocat aux
criminels sur rennes
je préfère que m alors qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour vous de travailler votre
complice oui ça faisait quand même
quinze ans qu'on avait mal tourné
ensemble j'aurais pris fihri fait une
déclaration volontaire à l'impôt mais
attend que soumet des transports s'est
risqué à mon âge depardieu disait que
chaque année un conte pour tous je pense
qu'il a raison c'est plate à dire mais
et ça va ça moi étant déjà bah oui ça
fait 15 ans qu'on n'a pas tourné
ensemble et j'ai retrouvé cette même
complicité là avec lui mon sixième film
avec denys arcand quand même alors on a
développé comme moi je dirais un langage
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'eux
parlez beaucoup pour se comprendre ou
des fois les phrases ne finissent même
par à 8 veut dire à bon droit la
compassion la justice sont des notions
étrangères à l'histoire
justement votre carrière en 1986 dans
lequel un père un délai d'environ 10 km
c'est vraiment là que ça décolle pour
vous non oui et au théâtre et à la
télévision
moi c'est le cinéma qui m'a fait
connaître ses rares normalement c'est la
télévision et à partir de ce film là
vraiment ça a été pour moi un changement
de carrière total le mensonge et la base
de la vie amoureuse comme ces ciment de
la lys qui c'est drôle parce que quand
je revois le déclin et je me dis oh mon
dieu mais
le personnage avait marqué avait marqué
le cinéma aux revues aussi d'engis de
montréal dans les boys d'un incendie est
ce qu'avec le recul aujourd'hui vous
vous dites pas ça c'était un de mes
meilleurs films où il ya quelque chose
de magique que je ne pourrai plus
reproduire aujourd'hui je pense les
invasions barbares c'était quand même un
autre match on a comme acteur pour moi
personnellement comme étant ma carrière
était bien amorcée à ce moment là c'est
j'ai fait d'autres schémas preppy duce
novembre mais pour moi le les invasions
c'est peut-être des films dont je suis
le plus fier toute ma vie durant je me
suis endormi avec les plus belles femmes
de la terre jusqu'au jour fatal je me
suis réveillé un matin en réalisant que
je m'étais endormi la veille en pensant
à la mer des caraïbes
j'étais devenu vieux le public vous aime
beaucoup
résultat rémy girard 55 films 35
télésérie est ce qu'un certain moment où
vous vous êtes dit c'est trop
j'en fais trop ça m'a été dit c est un
moment oui où je trouvais que c'était
trop mais les choses les les choses les
projets la vie fait bien les choses il
ya j'ai eu un creux après le film les
bougon qui m'a permis de
de relaxer un peu et puis de prendre le
pouls avec moi même avec ma famille vit
de ce puits monfils aussi beaucoup parce
que j'étais avec lui beaucoup de sang
dans ces temps là et puis même j'ai
pensé à bombay ça y est l'heure de la
retraite est arrivée
peut-être mais non pas du tout est ce
que vous venez de me dire que rémy
girard a vraiment pensé qu'un jour ce
serait terminé pour lui c'est lamentable
c'est tout là haut c'est fini ça s'est
arrêté
c'est un moment où j'étais plus
tranquille mais vous avez raison vous en
avait déjà parlé
un des plus grands rôles de votre vie et
celui de père de famille vous avez un
garçon lourdement handicapés oui
j'imagine qu'il vous a permis en quelque
sorte de relativiser les hauts et les
bas de toute carrière artistique de tout
ce qui nous arrive dans la vie je vous
dirai pas ce que je suis je suis
monoparentales sa mère est décédée
oui quand j'ai vu tous les efforts que
lui faisait pour essayer de survivre et
tout c'est sûr que ça va là tu vises tes
problèmes et je dis bon lui et peut pas
manger de seul il peut pas marcher
permanent est un garçon j'ai pris un
petit goût du vin était un accord ces
plus petits qu'eux mais pour moi c'est
comme si quand même évident le fond et
puis mais ça enlève pour le stress on
peut pas être parfait
merci
[Musique]